hello everyone as Mohammed said my name
is sumit Kumar I work at Microsoft I am
a program manager in the machine
learning group at Microsoft and one of
the things that I do is integrate Python
and are in sequel server so that you can
do in database machine learning and
today I'm going to talk precisely about
that in database machine learning with
Python so welcome again and how many
folks here are from outside of Seattle
quite a few so Seattle is beautiful like
this always never rains here thank you
for bringing the nice weather alright so
here's the quick agenda I will introduce
the concept of in database machine
learning and why does it really matter
and what are the advantages and I'll
walk through a lot of concepts using a
demo where I do the prediction of the
length of patient stay at hospital based
on the historical and other data and
then I'll touch upon various scale
performance and security aspects
etcetera and I'll try to save about five
minutes in the end for question and
answers and I'll stick around afterwards
as well for any other questions and if
we have more time I'll cover some other
bonus materials how many of you here use
sequel the language on a regular basis
about half how many of you use sequel
server the product and database product
about 1/3 of folks of course everybody
uses or is interested in pythons are not
gonna ask that question anyone familiar
or heard about sequel server our
services before ma the time
that's good ok
so you might have seen this recent most
recent survey from Kadena gates about
the popular tools and software used in
data science and as you can see Python R
and sequel are the top three
and of course Python is the top one this
year and it has been the fastest growing
over the last three years so what we are
doing with sequel server machine
learning services is is bringing these
top languages closer to the data right
there in the database
and you can combine Python and sequel in
interesting ways python and RN c RN
sequel and interesting ways to leverage
the strengths of the different languages
and achieve sort of more efficiency n
and performance and scale and the idea
overall is that the paradigm in the past
was that database is used to get the
data and you pull the data in your
application and you built build the
Python based or are based intelligence
and models in the application and that
sits in the application and there are
lots of issues involved in that that I
will talk about in a bit from that
paradigm to the situation where you move
the intelligence and the models right
where the data is in the database and
that data the intelligence in the models
become another Enterprise asset that any
number of applications can just get
access to that intelligence by
connecting to the database so from
regular data base to intelligence base
intelligent databases is where we are
trying to go so building further on why
does it matter why not just use ODBC or
JDBC to connect with data and do it
right I already touched upon this a
little bit first and the biggest
advantage is rather than taking data to
the compute you bring compute to the
data your
data movement completely there are a
number of benefits just from that moving
data massive amounts of data that are
required for machine learning deep
learning type applications is often it's
just not easy to do
you have to build massive amount of data
movement infrastructure that is if you
are allowed to do that many times
because of the security and the
compliance restrictions it is just not
allowed you cannot move data around and
even if you are allowed to you're often
forced to you know move samples of data
then you are as a data scientist you are
limited to working examples that means
in some algorithms in some cases your
accuracy is hampered because of the
amount of data available to you and then
also the sort of security concerns etc
right so if you're working in database
you are able to do your training and
model development in database a lot of
those issues are just gone
now once you've developed the model and
the Python scripts putting on R scripts
by the way whatever I say about Python
applies to R as well because we've added
our in 2016 release of sequel server and
in upcoming 2017 release of sequel
server we are adding Python support as
well so so let's see the data scientist
team has now built beautiful models
putting that in production where it is
available to all the apps is there a lot
of challenge challenges involved right
so we've heard stories from our
customers where the data science team
would build the model and hand it over
back to the the app developer tool and
then application development team would
literally translate that model
coefficients etc into the language of
application B Java c-sharp etc and
there's fidelity loss in that and that
the latency involved in sort of
translating
all of that caused a lot of pain in the
overall process there is if you now do
operationalization using sequel server
what you are doing is you're embedding
the Python Python code or R code right
there inside a TC code stored procedure
and the applications just make a TC code
stored procedure call and get all of
that smarts without oftentimes even
being aware that something of that sort
there is Python or R code running in
there and then the model models just
become you know a binary data that you
store in sequel server as well and
managing different versions of models
and doing a/b testing is all
substantially simpler by just sort of
using different versions of binary data
stored in sequel tables we third
advantages the enterprise greatness of
all of this right
first we be built on top of the open
source R and Python and we have a couple
of libraries one of them is Revo scalp I
and other one is Microsoft ml package
I'll talk more about that in detail but
what they do is they offer a number of
parallelized and scalable algorithms for
common predictive learning tasks and
machine learning and then there they're
able to leverage all the course and they
are able to do MPI based parallelization
because of that they can scale to data
that is much larger than what memory is
available to it and then sequel server
itself has decades of innovation and
performance and scale and security
resource governance compliance all of
that now becomes available to your
machine learning models and environments
as well so one of the things for example
is the in-memory querying capability in
sequel server and the column storing
this is now you combine all of those
innovations with the scaleable paralyzed
versions of Revo scale paella rhythms
then you really get tremendous amounts
of
tremendous performance advantages right
so jumping into what exactly do we get
when we install sequel server in the
sequel so it is integrated completely
with the product including the setup so
machine learning services is just
another feature in sequel server so you
have the option to choose either R or
Python or both so if you choose Python
what you get is when you have to go
through the content content screen and
you get a subset of popular anaconda
distribution a subset of that package is
included as part of the setup so let me
actually show you some code and how does
it look
don't forget the screen
so running Python code just taking the
Python code and running it in T sequel
inside a sequence of identity sequel
script is just as simple as pasting this
bit of Python code the hello world
inside of a t/n script under SP executes
external script let me free run this I
get hello world as expected so what this
is is a special system stored procedure
that understands decode for different
languages our Python and our right but
then we then there's just the simple you
know lift and shape type thing it offers
some additional sort of tight
integration with sequel so again this is
a slightly more complicated version of
example of a TC code stored procedure
with embedded Python code here I'm just
taking doing a simple sub setting okay
but what I am doing here is I can pass
any sequel query the results of any
sequel query as input data to this
Python script I can also pass a number
of parameters like I'm passing in this
case I'm passing an input parameter and
an output parameter so if I again run
the string now I get the sub setting of
that temporary table that I built before
any questions at this point
yes sir again
yes absolutely it can create returned
output data set as well at also more
complicated example later
all right so a little bit about sort of
how the what the architecture looks like
this thing works so we have integrated
the Python and our run run times in the
database as in it's not running inside
of the sequel server process but in the
database server machine so what happens
is when you saw that SP execute code is
my mouse cursor visible now okay let's
see now
okay here so when the execution it when
it sees the special SP execute external
script system stored procedure what
sequel server process does is there is a
another process that we have built
called service that keeps running called
launchpad service it then invokes an
external runtime through appropriate
launcher based on the parameter language
in this case it's Python so it launches
the Python process and this Python
process is sort of a separate process
now running on the same machine and this
is running under a different local users
with the local user called MS sequel
server r01 which has very low privileges
to ensure that the Python cannot that
code code script cannot do arbitrary
things and then when the RX or the Revo
scale PI or microsoft ml algorithms are
used then it invokes another bxo server
process running in there which basically
runs all the algorithms in native code
C++ code and then this has a high
throughput columnar data communication
channel with sequel server process to to
have directing the hyper fast
communication that's how it achieves a
lot of performance gate ok so I talked
about the in addition to this
integration tight integration I talked
about a couple of libraries in the form
of packages so one of them is revoscaler
pi
so Microsoft acquired a company called
revolution analytics some of you may
have heard I have people who used to
work there I tend also so as part of
that we got this library now we have a
pythonic version of this library and
what it has is a number of algorithms
that work in a again scalable and
performant way I will show exactly how
it does that it has a linear and
logistic regression trees forest booster
tweezer and etc and in addition to that
it allows you to work in different
compute context for example you can work
locally on your client or you can work
on a remote server including sequel
server in this case and in our case we
have other things but we are building
additional compute context for Python
and it also has a bunch of other
concepts like data sources you can point
to a ODBC data or sequel server data or
there is an additional sort of xdf data
source that that sort of has a again
very on disk
highly compressed columnar data
structure that we have and it has SAS
data step type of functionality and it
gives you additional utilities for data
import summarization etc right so how
this thing works is calling a Revo scale
PI function is very similar to calling
the other regular Python functions
analytic functions but internally what
it does is there is a initiator
component which takes care of
distributing the job across multiple
different tasks and then each task gets
chunks of data from disk on loaded onto
the memory so basically because of that
you can work with arbitrarily large data
sets so you are not bound to working
with data sets that fit in your memory
and the entire thing is written in
performance C++ code so that's how you
get additional performance advantages
and as I said before you can either work
on this on the local data or you can
work on the remote computer context I'll
show one example later as well so this
thing whole thing is called parallel
external memory algorithms similarly the
other library that we have is basically
sort of a collection of Microsoft
internal battle-tested algorithms that
we have harvested from different parts
of Microsoft products some from being
some from Xbox Live etcetera and we have
packaged that in this library and we are
making it part of sequel server so among
other things it has a deep neural act
for example which you can use to Train
deep neural nets and in addition to
these algorithms we now have some pre
trained models that are available for
you to consume right away so for example
training an image feature Iser is very
complex saying it involves expertise
massive amounts of computing resources
and so on and time right so this library
includes a number of award-winning
pre-trained image feature is the models
like ResNet 1850 101 and alex net
etcetera for Microsoft Research which is
available dry up to you without any of
the other pre-cleaned model that it has
is called sentiment analysis model where
you from English text it can extract
sentiment scores and then in addition to
these things that also has a number of
transforms extracting engrams from text
doing categorical transformations and
feature selections etc although that is
available to you so I'll now get a
little show you a demo with actual
working code in this demo I'm guru I
talked about it before I'm going to show
you an application that relies on the
predictions of the length of stay for a
patient when the patient is admitted
and I'll show how we have done the
training and but before that this is how
sort of the workflow is right so as a
data scientist you're working in your ID
PTDS or PyCharm
or node whatever it is right but I don't
want to pull data there I want to be
able to work on the entire data set that
is available in my database so you can
just work remotely and do remote compute
context into your sequel server machine
and your script even though you are in
your ID the actual execution is
happening on the sequel server box and
result results are returned back to your
ID so you're able to do complete
experimentation exploration and model
development right there in your ID you
don't leave your familiar environment
and you can leverage these sort of
additional compute capacity available on
the sequel server machine which is in
general a higher than what our data
scientists client desktop ass so that's
the data scientist part now when you are
happy with the model and you are ready
to operationalize again you put that
model in T sequel stored procedure with
an embedded you know Python code with
model and the application or reports or
dashboards are just making a stored
procedure call and getting the results
back imagine sort of the traditional
three-tier architecture where you have
the thing in between and maintaining
version consistency and all of that is
very problematic there so you don't have
to worry about any of that the app in
fact isn't even aware that something
like this is happening okay so let's
switch to that demo machine
so what you're seeing here is a power bi
desktop version and it is a dashboard
and app for in the healthcare system
where hospitals unlike unlike hotels for
example when you you check-in you kind
of know the lengths that you're going to
stay and II the hotel management of
those tasks and accordingly you know
manage them various sources that way but
in the hospital you don't know whether
you're going to be there for a day or
you know a week or longer and so for the
administrators and doctors it is a
little bit of a challenge to make sure
that they have allocated the right kind
of resources and staffing so if they are
able to predict that in the length of
stay they can make a lot of adjustments
and gain efficiencies because of that
alright so for example this dashboard is
for a care line manager who's
responsible for specific wards so if she
wants to know hey how many people are
going to be released in six days from
now and so a six days in general so she
knows from that that Oh Saturday she has
a lot of patients getting discharged so
she better have the discharged nurses
lined up on that day right so d she's
able to make that kind of business
decisions based on this prediction
similarly for different persona here the
chief medical information officer for
that Hospital he can look at you know
the average length of stay and the
number of patients that are going to be
in different wards then he can shift
around resources doctors nurses etc
accordingly right so I'm not going to go
to pin too deep into this actual
business follow but the point here is
that the the business problem was solved
based on this prediction that we were
able to make
so as a data scientist
I'll work I work in my IDE so I'm using
vs code and I do the regular things here
data pre-processing and feature
generation from the data that I have a
lot deep into all of that and then then
I do the training let's walk through
this code a little bit so in this thing
I will connect connect to database and
get the data that I need to do training
I split data into training and
evaluation set and then I train a couple
of different models random forests and
boosted tree models and then I do
break-ins based on that on my test data
and evaluate and compare and when I'm
happy with that then I am ready to put
it in production break let me just run
this thing and then show you the code
while this is happening in the
background so the interesting bits of
code are here for example so now this
line is where I'm are you available to
see the code clearly okay
so this line is where I'm setting the
compute context to sequel somewhere
above here because I'm differ so I'm
here I'm defining the connection string
using which I am I'm giving it the right
sort of connection to the sequel server
where I'm working and then Here I am
setting the compute context to sequel
that means the subsequent lines of code
are actually not being executed here it
is the execution is happening in sequel
server so here I'm using a training a
force model using RHD forest algorithm
and I'm giving it the D formula which I
have defined before and I'm specifying
other parameters of this algorithm and
when the results come back in the local
a Python memory in in this moment
environment I now need to write that
model back into sequel server so I use
the rx right object API again this is
part of vivo scale PI package to write
that thing in a sequel table similarly
klar here I do this exact same thing I
am cleaning a booster tree model and I
am writing the model back into sequel
server table down below here I am doing
the prediction on the data using the
model that was stored in sequel server
and on the evaluation data set and I do
the predictions for both forest model
and for the the booster tree model and I
do the comparisons to see which one has
a better performance let's see this is
completed running so the execution here
is done and I see that the the error
based on that the error for the random
forest model is is better so I the
random forest model quality seems to be
better and now happy to sort of ready to
put it in production so then what I do
is I go into sequel server come on
so I can do the entire training and data
processing everything in here as part of
the embedded as part of this TCO stored
procedure with by embedded Python code
but I'm not going to show you the repeat
of all of that let me show you how I do
this coding now the random forest model
all the models data everything is
securely stored inside of sequel server
the data is never leaving it's in sequel
server tables in this case I am going to
use the random forest model and I'm
giving it a query and select select star
from the nos table
which I which was has the features that
I prepared in the feature feature
generation step and and then I'm
creating a output that is populated in a
data set that is being used by the that
power bi dashboard so if I execute this
and it is actually calling a stored
procedure call
score so let me show you what's
happening in that stored procedure so it
came and it did the generated the data
output data so this is where the listing
for a second so this is an
ordinary-looking
TCO stored procedure right but in there
this is the new system stored procedure
that I was talking about it takes Python
language as a parameter and a a script
which is under this thing I will show in
a bit and it is taking model name that
was another parameter that was passed by
the driving script it takes the model
and it is taking the inquiry which is
the Select star statement and it is
taking database name and some of the
parameters etc and it is passing all of
this into this stored procedure which
basically has the same T prediction code
that I showed you in the ID so exact
same code running inside of T so T
sequel stored procedure and doing the
things right I'm doing the exact same
set of things here so so that's sort of
how you using this integration you can
do both from your ID as well as inside
of TCO stored procedure and the apps are
now sort of able to generate reports and
this is sort of the end to end story
here any questions
yes great
can you speak up a little bit or come
closer
so it's going to work like that mrs
currently does where you have a free
version at Enterprise version ah
so how does the licensing work is
affected at you so this is part of
sequel server you don't pay a dime extra
to get this feature so now and it is
available in all the editions of sequel
server windows-only thus far so if you
have an Express SKU with advanced
features you get it but the performance
is a little bit throttle if you have
already paid for an Enterprise version
will give you the full fully performant
version of it but you don't pay anything
extra for it that's all we go yeah and
as far as ISO it's called vo scale
Python or whatever so it's a
compatibility going to be the same
between say mriswith operationalization
snapshotting with the repos and all that
absolutely but I didn't talk about all
of that because we are still working on
those things but as I indicated
initially sort of the our goal is to
have parity with what you see in our
okay any other question okay
hi um my question relates to storage and
skill so um because we're talking mostly
about big data possibly unstructured and
although I'm not aware that secret
server storage currently supports you
know unstructured data so I suppose the
question that arises out of here if
you're doing this in the cloud
I'm assuming that you spin up what VM
with a secret server instance on the B
and that has logically our services on
it then question arises as to where the
data that you're going to be desk and
serve as your input is going to say you
could potentially have it in a blob
storage say in Azure or sort of oels way
I just wanted you to talk about that
whole scenario and how it will work
because data can and do leave in all
sorts of places the way we work with
seeker server traditionally is that you
know the data that you want a process
for analytics purposes tend to sit in
the sequel server instance storage so
how does how does um you know secret are
asked secret Microsoft our services
secrets of our services support working
with you know extremely large scale data
potentially stored outside of the
distrito server itself sure excellent
question so first of all reason why we
have integrated the machine learning
services in the databases - for you to
be able to do analytic advanced
analytics and machine learning on the
data that is already there in sequence
of all right so for a lot sort of a lot
of cases people have the entire data in
sequin and then they are moving it
around to do that so that problem is
solved and that's one of the main main
goals now what if your data happens to
be outside of sequel server and the
question is in that case why do we want
to do it the analytics of training in
sequel server the magical reasons for it
so there are some options for that if
you wanted to pull the data in sequel
server you can do things where
the poly bass is a way to sort of
connect additional data sources into
sequel server now if you want to do
there is an interesting scenario here
where so the hybrid scenario where
you're training the models on big data
elsewhere on the cloud on Hadoop
clusters and then you take that model
and you operationalize that model in
sequel server now that is the more
likely and common scenario so for that
you have a few other alternatives like
for example on HD insight we have our
server running there and in future we'll
have Python as well all on Prem Hadoop
cluster you have our server there so you
train your model on big unstructured
data and then your model is ready you
deploy that model in sequel server where
your online transaction data is coming
in the Neuse course why if you talk to
me afterwards I will show you in a demo
of exactly that where we train a model
on HD inside operationalize the
consequence over I have a question so I
understood the writing the code so when
you are showing the BI application for
this scenario when we have Python or R
how the interfaces are connected to the
BI ah so this is standard power bi
desktop connecting into sequel server
and getting that so that there is got
nothing to do with our or Python
integration it's just a data output data
table that was created based on the
predictions from that algorithm and then
it's just hooking up that it so it is
just another column that says predicted
length of stay and it's just reading
that thing so so I'll move along because
I think I have just five minutes left I
want to talk about okay so the developer
sorry so the developer is happy and the
data scientist is happy so there's one
important constituency which is the
database administrators how they they
don't want any random third party sort
of runtime running in their machine so
we have made sure that we address their
concerns as well so by design it has
very very secure
so we make sure that this whole sort of
the external script execution is
disabled by default so only when you
explicitly enable it is this allowed and
and as I showed in the architecture
diagram it is running in a separate
process so no matter what the Python
script does it is not gonna impact your
sequence or process itself and even if
the script execution is allowed these
specific users need explicit permissions
to do that just because you can access
the database you cannot run this scripts
and and so so that's another level of
control and as I should set before the
the Python and our process is run under
the makes make sure that these are
isolated processes and they are running
on the very low user note there is a
special local user that is created which
has low privileges you can't that script
can't even it's running behind a
firewall so it cannot do communications
with the external Network and so on
right so we have made short and then two
separate processes running Python script
cannot talk to each other so we made
sure that lot of isolation and other
things are in place in addition to this
we have resource governance like the
traditional sequel server resource
governance functionality is now extended
for the external resources also external
runtime as well so you can do things
like by default about twenty to twenty
percent of the memory is allocated for
external processes external runtime but
you can change and you can reduce or it
can increase it you can even determine
the you know those things like CPU
affinity and so on so there are a lot of
DMVs built into the system for you to
monitor these external runtime is etc so
so basically we have made sure that DBAs
are okay with running these things as
well I think at the end of the talk and
so I encourage you to try out the CTP to
over
see to be too and I think later versions
of sequels over 2017 that has this thing
and there are bunch of samples that we
have put out and provide feedback to us
my email address is submit dot Kumar at
my croissant and Mohamed mentioned the
title was changed in the LA end because
I was supposed to do a deep learning app
demo in this talk but I'm going to do
that demo in Joseph solutions keynote
tomorrow so if you're around please come
for that and I'll show another
application and at this point thank you
so much for your time
[Applause]